You know, writing letters to yourself, by the way,
is such a clever idea.
And I know it's a conceit for the story line,
but writing
Yeah.
is such a powerful thing.
For sure.
For me, it's songwriting is how I get all of my,
you know, feelings that I'm having difficulty processing
or experiences that I don't quite understand out.
It's a really cathartic kind of outlet to have,
to just express things, similarly to theater,
and that you can't express by chatting.
And your new album
that I'm so excited about.
(audience cheering)
I mean, first of all,
(Ben chuckles)
(audience clapping)
Now, you wrote this quarantined in your bedroom.
(Ben agreeing)
which sounds almost like childhood rather than like,
this is your adult, you know, dream album.
What was it like writing this album
in your childhood bedroom?
Being in my, I moved home for the pandemic
to live with my parents
and staying in my childhood bedroom
and seeing all of my theater posters on the wall
and my old clothes and stuff,
I felt this really weird,
limbo where I was caught between all this nostalgia
and like my teen self and who I used to be
and what I used to care about.
And then all of a sudden feeling like,
a little more evolved and adult-ish and you know,
in a new relationship.
And just feeling so different from that now.
And I think being caught between those two worlds
in that bedroom is like,
ended up being a really inspiring place to write.
And that's kind of where the whole album came from.
So I wrote a lot of it over zoom with my co-writers
on my little keyboard that's still in my bedroom
and then, it came out. (chuckles)
So you quarantined in LA and now you're back in New York.
Ish. I'm kind of all over the place
because of the film and promoting and stuff and-
Traveling again?
Yes, and my boyfriend works
on the show called "The Good Doctor,"
so he shoots in Vancouver.
So I'm trying to be close to the west whenever I can.
But, New York is where my heart is and where I want to be,
so I'm hoping to be here
for the long run.
(Drew clears throat)
Well, I have a quick, rapid fire questions
for you about New York.
Okay.
If you will. It's called "New York Minute!"
(audience cheering)
I like that they have the horns in there.
(Ben and Drew laughing)
Okay! Start it now!
Favorite date spot?
(timer clicking)
Oh! Uh, ABC Cocina, a really yummy restaurant.
Oh! Yes, okay!
Best New York bagel?
Oh, god! Um, um,
a bodega bagel!
Okay! Best spot for people watching?
Oh, um, maybe Prospect Park is fun.
(Drew delightfully agrees)
Favorite view of the city?
Oh, from my apartment window.
(Drew squeals)
(audience laughing)
Best place to cry?
My bed. (laughing)
(audience laughing)
Best New York pizza?
Francesco's on the upper west side.
Oh! Hitting that today.
Best coffee?
Um, Starbucks? (laughing)
(audience laughing)
Good. Best subway line?
Best subway? Oh, the one,
I use the one the most.
Hmm, worst subway line?
(Ben clicks teeth)
Um, they're all fine!
Okay, perfect. (mumbles)
Favorite New York movie?
Ooh. Oh, that's so hard.
I know.
Oh, well this is called "New York Minute,"
so "New York Minute,"
the Ashley, Mary-Kate Olsen movie. (laughing)
Perfect!
(audience cheering)
Oh, that is so fun!
What place, you wanted to go,
but never have had the chance?
(buzzer noise)
(Drew screams)
Uh, uh. Oh, Coney Island!
I've never been to Coney Island.
No way, really?
Okay. (Drew squealing)
(Ben laughing)
Well, we're going to get you to Coney Island,
by the way.
(audience cheering)
Phew!
Can I go to Coney Island with you?
Yeah.
Seriously?
Yeah, let's go!
Okay, and before you go,
we wanted to do a little something
to celebrate your birthday!
So we got you these!
(Ben gasps)
Nick!
(audience cheering)
Hi, it's so good to meet you.
Hi handsome
Hey Nick
Nick Dodani, ladies and gentlemen!
(audience cheering)
Happy birthday!
Thank you.
Nick and,
they play best friends in the movie
in "Dear Evan Hansen."
Family friends.
(Ben chuckles)
And so, who better to call on
than your real life and cinematic best friend.
(Ben gasps)
(audience awes)
Oh my God.
You got to look at them.
(audience cheering)
So cute.
How great is this?
They're so cute.
And I'm wondering if we could go out
on "Happy Birthday" to Ben song.
(audience cheering)
And, one, two, three
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
♪ Happy birthday, dear Ben ♪
(song drowns out Ben speaking)
(audience cheering)
Thank you.
Thank you all.
(audience applauding)
"Dear Evan Hansen" is in theaters now,
but today everyone in the audience is going home
with a copy of the soundtrack.
(audience cheering)
Thank you Nick Dodani for showing up!
Yeah, thank you for having me.
Good to meet you.
Thank you to the audience!
(audience cheering)
We get to sing to Ben!
And, now you get to take it home with you!
(upbeat pop music)